just days ago
kanye west delivered a freewheeling
political speech
surrounded by cameras one of america's
biggest music stars is trying to run for
u.s
president but his erratic statements
recently and
tweets since deleted has sparked
confusion and concern
now his wife kim kardashian west has
publicly addressed the issue on
instagram for the first time the reality
tv star said
he is a brilliant but complicated person
who on top of the pressures of being an
artist and a black man
who experienced the painful loss of his
mother
has to deal with the pressure and
isolation that is heightened by his
bipolar disorder
those who are close with kanye know his
heart and understand his words sometimes
do not align
with his intentions the mother of four
said she felt
compelled to speak up because of the
stigma and misconceptions about mental
health
last year her husband also spoke about
bipolar disorder
mental health advocates say well-known
stars
can help to raise public awareness i
think what
celebrities bring to this discussion is
that level of influence and the scope of
that influence that they can have
in the ways in which people often look
up to them as voices
and as artists it helps to reduce the
stigma
by demonstrating that it is something
that we can talk about that it's
something that's treatable
and that others who are experiencing
similar things are not alone
kanye west's presidential bid has
subjected him to
even more attention and scrutiny
his wife is asking instead for
compassion
and empathy cordelia lynch sky news
washington